yesterday juno star elliot page revealed
that he was transgender and stars like
patrick stewart
to anna kendrick to tegan and sarah all
shared their support
even prime minister justin trudeau
shared a message tweeting this thank you
elliot
for sharing these words and speaking
your truth your bravery and strength are
inspiring
and your authenticity and vulnerability
will mean so much to so many sophie and
i wish you the very best
and we send you and the trans community
all our support
[Music]
now once the announcement was made
netflix tweeted this
so proud of our superhero we love you
elliot can't wait to see you return
in season three and we can now confirm
that elliot page will continue to play
the role of vanya hargreaves on
netflix's series the umbrella
academy which i just love so much vania
is a cisgender woman whose superpower
involves unleashing force through the
use of sound there are no plans to
change the character's gender insiders
have told
variety yeah i'm glad nick adams added
this trans actors can
and do play both trans and cisgender
characters i'm sure elliot will continue
to be brilliant in umbrella academy
and many different types of roles in the
future uh elliot's name has already been
updated on the umbrella academy's imdb
page and we have been told uh that his
name will be
updated as well on all the netflix
services across
all the titles he's been involved with
[Music]
so what are your thoughts roz i just
want the umbrella academy to come back
because i think that you know what i'm
saying about this
i read this i wrote this letter i have
been interviewing
um elliot page for years for as long as
i've been
interviewing humans i've been
interviewing elliot
and i've sort of watched the
transformation from just
indie star to this like
you know academy award you know
nominations
as well as big giant blockbusters and
just
every step of their career has been
incredible
and um for me it all sort of capped off
with
umbrella academy to me umbrella academy
was the the sort of you know cherry on
the top of
everything that uh that they had done
and i agree i think that they'll be
brilliant in umbrella academy uh
regardless of everything else because
they are brilliant
yep i completely agree um adrian is
saying
oh yay so much love for elliott paige um
i don't know about you but obviously
this news is all over social media
yesterday and so when i was going
through everything you know my friends
not only in the industry but just
everyone around the world
there's such a feeling of pride i feel
like we all feel so proud
um for elliot and i don't i don't know
if it's because he's canadian too so
you know we all feel this extra sense of
you know
pride for him but i i just this is just
such a
a big deal um not only for the trans
community but um
elliot was just so vulnerable too in the
in the whole
message sent out to everyone um that
he's so happy but also that
uh he's fragile that he's scared um so
these are just really you know strong
messages and also saying i love
that i am trans i love that i am queer
so i
just very very strong messages so
empowering for the trans community and
and yeah
i'm really excited to see what happens
in the future and i only want more roles
more roles
and i only want to contribute to
positivity and i think that the most
positive thing i can say right now
is this
[Music]
all of you associated with that show get
your asses back on set
and get season three going because
that's what i need right now
okay i know i think okay agree
wait really quickly uh did you like
first season better or second season
oh that's really tough because i was so
in love
with the first season and um
we my whole family cheated on each other
with the first season that's how much we
all loved it
i was cheating on catherine watching it
alone
catherine was cheating on me watching it
alone and then our daughter who was
about
nine at the time took my laptop into her
room when we all fell asleep and cheated
on both of us
and then we all just lied to each other
and eventually we just watched the final
episode together
so ep so season one holds a big place in
my heart because it was such a big
family thing
um i didn't start off loving season two
and then i
really loved season two okay ross can i
just agree really quickly i was obsessed
with season one watched it a number of
times just even getting ready to go to
work season two was a slow start for me
and i actually stopped watching it
so so you're telling me i need to get
back into season two and finish it
oh god yes okay yes okay okay
okay i will do this i will do this
because you told me too
no i know but you said it gets it gets
yeah it does no it does it gets really
it gets really awesome